are you ready to gamble all of your
money
welcome to the gambling show Sims
vendrick left go back in the building
it's so amazing with this podcast how
like I have I have some friends who like
hate the gambling podcast and like our
deep dive podcast yeah and then I have
other friends that are the exact
opposite I don't know why I feel like we
good dives I know but some people just
don't care about that part of it I've
gotta do it you know we got something
for everybody yeah and we're gonna give
you a little bit of all of that in
Atlanta Josh you're here now you've been
Manning the The Sims and left go at
gmail.com we're blowing up yeah it's
gonna be a packed house really it's
gonna be a lot of fun 19:42 I'm thinking
I'm just gonna buy a couple bottles in
1942 right when we get to Atlanta and
just bring it to the bar oh yeah and
I'll just be like you guys are serving
okay I'm good for one we're just gonna
have we'll have one on the set yeah and
it'll just be continually replenished
throughout the week and then we'll put a
few behind the bar and say aid antenna
is you guys serve high-end tequila now
congruence these interviews are gonna
get sauce Tuesday at 5:00 Wednesday at
5:00 Thursday at 6:00 Friday at 4:30
we're gonna be hanging out there we're
like we have people coming up with like
games and trivia and like there's gonna
be a lot of guests that I'm not even
allowed to say right now but we're gonna
have a really good time really what
we're trying to do is is kind of hang
out with you guys
yeah because we've talked you've heard
our voices in your heads now for so long
it's not a funny way to think about a
podcast just voices in their heads
you left the oven on you did I've got a
turnaround Iquitos burning
speaking of chickens burning that's when
you're really gonna get upset that oh no
things are going awry and after a four
and a week that's got to be what's going
on in sims's head right yeah all ten
dollars that I lost Josh where are we
did his memory you want to do coaches
first uh look I just want an
establishing all right so in terms of
the money if now if he was winning we've
already would have established this
Monday Tuesday and Wednesday but I like
to dive in all week on this one coming
out of wildcard weekend Sims you are at
2100
and seventy bleacher bucks left go you
are at 1760 bleacher bucks okay so what
is that difference I don't know I'll do
that I don't do math okay so I took it
from 482 475
thanks to Kody parky unbelievable a
double doink made you ten bleacher bucks
how I didn't know like till Monday that
he had a thing about an Instagram thing
about hitting post oh he's out of the
job
you don't watch kicking her kick her
film no but I think that's like
purposely trying to work on his aim by
hitting posts right I don't I just
wouldn't work on that that would just
not be it's like I wouldn't practice
someone interceptions I don't know I
just you know that I think that was kind
of sad you like it was cool but right
hold on timeout he was using in this
target practice to try and aim right
down behind the goalpost and aim it down
the [ __ ] middle and hit it that way
that's right
you know like Steph Curry doesn't go and
like Joffrey I'm gonna try to knock it
off the edge of the rim and never go in
like that's right it just seems weird it
messes your karma it's all I'm saying I
guess my thing was like does he not live
around goal post cuz he was doing it off
light post yes right right I just
thought that was funny and kind of just
ironic I don't know I guess you're right
I guess have you would have practiced
just put it right to the right of that
post every time it's just and then that
way when he's doing he pretends to the
left post right I like juju I like that
word how you say bad juju yeah that's
like a that's a I feel like it's my
Jewish friends only use that is that a
Jewish that's just a thing that is okay
I'm gonna get some news going you're
gonna look at the etymology of juju your
wife it's okay from my little boy to say
Juke last night that's great and I was
like what do you mean she's like is Juke
a bad word and I was like no it means
you faked somebody actually okay good I
heard Phillip saying that a lot and I
was worried that much like Jewish people
deceived people in Merchant of Venice
yeah that my son would be deceiving them
by pretending to go left and going right
we're gonna get there as a society yeah
we hunt in 2025 Florio's gonna go and
you can't say Juke anymore say hey
Junior we do have a higher Adam GaSe
goes from Miami to New York yeah and if
you're a Jets fan and you're on social
media
tonight you were told how bad the hire
was the entire night welcome to Simpson
left go where you're gonna get the
counter opinion yes I don't know who
those people were because they're gonna
say gates went down to Miami right blew
up all the stars on the roster blamed it
on Tannehill blamed it on all this stuff
and he wasn't winning that that's what I
was seeing on Twitter okay well first of
all he doesn't blame it on tannenhill he
got fired there because he stuck up so
hard for Tannehill all the time that
he'd almost made himself look bad if
anybody's wondering and Dhamma can sue
has been average in the Rams and they're
paying him like he's Aaron Donald so
that worked out okay Jarvis Landry you
know was good but I think we've all seen
that
okay Jarvis Landry is not the superstar
we all thought he was I mean at the end
of the year he was the third option in
that past game right what do you think
of game Jets so just to go there but
then I am a fan of gays you know that
you know I I sit there and evaluate his
offense and I'm not gonna sit here and
lie to you and tell you that I'm just
whoa blown away by his offense but his
game always has rhyme or reason to it
it's usually detailed as far as what
they do on the offensive side of the
ball and they have a something that
they're trying to accomplish on a weekly
basis the other things I like about
Gates is he's a little bit Bruce Arians
ish where he he joins the team with the
quarterback and he goes through the
fight with him he makes run he made Ryan
Tennant feel like we're team I'm gonna
tell you that Sam dartle really liked
case when he met him great so there you
go I know this is a real dude you know
he's a dude that we would like you would
go like Oh could we go out of beer and
gays would be one of the coaches you'd
go like we could have a beer and have
real conversation I'm just gonna say
though I do not like that as a way of
defending somebody because that's how
George w was defended for eight years I
get you enjoyed George w - I did I do
not st. George so he's a big guy but the
number one thing was he's a president
you like to have a beer I'm just saying
there's other coaches in the world where
if we went out on a beer you big man
this is really boring and he's giving us
coach speak he's talking to us like it's
still the media right so that's what
you're saying his base is not afraid to
admit fault fault and admit his failure
had to go I [ __ ] up right so and this
was [ __ ] up about our situation like
wrecking
to you as a real he will be real I think
that's what rubs off on players he tried
to change the culture there in Miami
that's why he didn't want Seward our
Landry there because he knew they were
gonna hold him hostage for money and
everything like that and what Internet
really didn't like the fact that he
brought your boy down Logan see which is
absolutely insane I would argue the dow
Logan's offense was every bit as good as
Matt Nagy's in Chicago last year except
he just didn't have Alan Robinson or
Gabriel or Anthony Miller or Trey burden
or oh the whole offense right yeah
that's right so they would have been the
same exact offense they would have been
the same offense if dowels are there Dow
just became the scapegoat because people
just went whoa they're calm they're not
winning I mean the roster we talked
about it a million times last year tarik
Cohen was their best receiver like
literally lined up at receiver because
they were like damn we don't have
anybody else so we'll make Jordan Howard
their running back and we'll make Tariq
Cohen our wide receiver so again
unqualified people making qualifying
statements wipe that out of your brains
everybody and people what everybody is
did you guys want Mike McCarthy is that
what you wanted oh okay there's nobody
in football that wants to hire Mike
McCarthy right now Jets fans what did
you want did you want man I think it's
just fans okay it's just fans okay so
just other people jumping on it's just
the media right okay if there's there's
a few clusters of media that I'm seeing
online yeah there's the very qualified
that and they say something the word the
world moves right that's the chef ders
that's the Rappaport's around josita
Anderson's they're typically information
haver yeah then there's this analytics
community right I would say at the
forefront of that is Evans Silva of roto
world yes it's all of the guys that
wrote a world that they're looking at
numbers and they're also looking at
because look I will also argue that the
fantasy community is a very intelligent
community because they're looking at
football in an analytics way that this
other group which I would say is sports
writers write sports writers to me is
the least knowledgeable and if you edit
this I'm gonna get angry at you sports
writers to me the least knowledgeable
they're typically people that have been
in this space for 30 to 40 years and
they claim to watch film but even if
they did I don't even know if they know
how to watch film and they make very
bold claims and they never have to deal
with the repercussions
they're also the ones that are best at
writing tweets because they're used to
writing headlines right those are the
people that were really coming at gays
yeah also realize that we're having a
huge backlash that there's been no
minority hires and I totally understand
then that's totally like I completely
agree with it too
so the fact that GaSe was hired and he
wasn't winning in Miami it's hitting on
all of the accounts and their offense
wasn't good even though you go wow
Tannehill his quarterbacks were
Tannehill and Brock Osweiler and all
those people would say Brock Osweiler
sucks but they're gonna blame Adam GaSe
for not winning with Brock Osweiler yeah
it's it's the same thing that I said
about Sean McVeigh an outlier right you
acknowledge that Sean McVeigh is an
outlier and then go
but let's hire a Sean McVeigh keung
right it doesn't make sense it doesn't
make sense in case again if gays had a
mistake in Miami - he had total control
over the roster and I don't think that
was right so if I was gonna put the
negatives about what he did down there
yes yeah that would be what I would look
at and go yeah his he couldn't balance
both he wasn't ready to be Bill
Belichick there yet and then he didn't
have a lot of great minds in the front
office to really build the team properly
I mean you can't look at Miami and go
wow that's a talented team they really
messed that up I mean no one's gonna go
you know what it probably was gays his
fault because I have trust in Mike
Tannenbaum he like no one's ever gonna
say that exactly right so he did well
with Tannehill right he did well with
ten anybody can say without they went
ten and six and he antenna Hill was hurt
and they went to the playoffs with Sean
Sean more okay more Matt more excuse me
remember and Pittsburgh yeah right so
they lost that last year they were in
the conversation for the playoffs into
the last few weeks of the season so okay
and there was a lot of dysfunction that
happened last year we're talking in that
the 2017 season 2018 they were
competitive yeah they weren't perfect
but they were again a chance for early
December again right and you look at
their roster and go how is he buddy they
always beat the teams they were supposed
to beat that's the one thing I like
about Adam GaSe do to me which shows a
tough coach right and the other thing I
like about gays he's shown no fear of
New England and if you're in the AFC is
true your decisions have to be made
about New England they're the kings of
the world and they definitely own the
AFC East and you need a guy that can
kind of combat the detail toughness of
New
and be the same way that's why I think
McDermott's gonna give them a tough time
too but the only other question for
young guess is this right case is a low
hat brim not a mumble talker but I'm not
here for the [ __ ] right how is that
gonna play in New York it could go
either way they're right I think is it
winning the New York's gonna go the New
York media is annoying let him go he's a
good coach but if it's not going well
it could really turn quickly on gay it
definitely could I think he fits what
Jets fans are all about them Jets fans
are blue-collar right no nonsense Giants
fans are a little uppity in white collar
you go to a Giants game and it's a lot
of older men drinking whiskey and
smoking 50 dollar cigars we go to a Jets
game
it's Jersey it's unwise yeah let's stand
all game and we're gonna yell cusses at
the other team and we're gonna cheer our
team even though we're like two and ten
and we're gonna go crazy for him like
I'm sure I'm sure Giants fans would go
oh you have a chant that's cute
like Giants would be like we're above
cheer like we don't spell out our game
and just like New York money punch them
in the face and be like J right right
and last thing I'll say about fire
fighters they are it's it's a blue
that's why the Jets and Mets were
invented nobody could get tickets to see
the yankees and giants because you had
to be rich to have the season tickets
there last thing I'll say about gates -
you got a young quarterback in Sam
darlin first of all who were the options
that were out there that were better
than Adam GaSe right okay the Jets have
had this long lineage of defensive
coaches have you noticed that I mean the
Jets haven't hired an offensive coach
since I don't even know was rich coach
tight and often to coach but it was he
was it wrecks ourselves Belichick bowls
her Minette Herm Edwards
Rex Rex so there's five coaches in a
rugged than all defense is good to see
them change that aspect of it and
whether you like Tannehill or not case
made him outperform Jay Cutler had a
career year in cases last year in
Chicago okay he made Tim Tebow a
feasible quarterback and I know we're
all gonna sit here and go oh yeah coach
Peyton Manning he didn't need Peyton
Manning hey I get that but if he was
really horrible
you would have heard that Peyton Manning
hated Adam GaSe and I
no that's not the truth I know a Peyton
Manning really respected Adam GaSe and I
would also say Gates was smart enough to
realize when when Peyton Manning's like
physical skills started to go down Lefko
he was very good at going okay we'll
throw you know seven bubble screens and
twenty-four pick plays a game and not
try to make you throw the ball down the
field cuz that's not your strength
anymore so I think those are all pops I
think the reason this is I'm gonna wrap
it up on this yeah I think the reason
the fantasy and the analytics community
turned on gays this year is because of
Kenyan Drake every time I went to these
websites to research for our shows and
get ready for all that stuff it was why
is the best player in your team not
getting the ball and it's truly the
question that I still have not answered
sure because when I watch the Texans
game that Thursday Night Football when I
watched Kenyan Drake against the
Patriots I went this guy needs to be
featured yeah and I don't know if it's
because he was an impending free agent
and they were trying to get the market
down or if they were just trying to make
history with Frank Quinn a bumbling
problem yes and and they didn't trust
him
I don't think for the early part of his
career that's the one thing I've you
know Drake can you drink even coming out
of Alabama that was the mo on him that
he was a little immature that way and he
needed to be you know more professional
you ready to break news are you ready to
break are you ready are you ready for
Simms to say something yes that you're
gonna go I need to get a quote card made
hit me there is rumors right now that
Kyler Murray is going to enter the NFL
Draft
there are roomie rumors that the Oakland
A's are gonna let him perform in the
combine I'm not even gonna look at them
yeah Sims you've believed this before
the championship game what kind of a
career do you think Kyler Murray would
have in the NFL well I think listen
Kyler Murray can just get to the point
column or it can be a star in the NFL I
don't give a damn what his height is or
whatever it is an inch and a half
shorter than Baker may feel that Baker
Mayfield was the number one pick that I
don't think Kyle Emery should be too far
off he's faster than Baker Mayfield his
arm is just as strong this is how I was
like so no no no my bad my bad Dan you
picked the wrong corner but I did
champion you are you ready to make news
Sims this is wait what kind of a career
would to a Tonka file oh I have in the
NFL oh okay okay
that's where you wanted to go but I
didn't mean to I [ __ ] up all right but
you just give your to a talk with Tyler
Murray
first of all okay just we gotta say that
police just I'll get there shut up Kyler
Murray is really talented though I mean
he's a freak of nature in a lot of ways
so okay so now going back to 2ax at
Alabama you know to to uh for me at this
point is not a first round quarterback I
don't know what else to say there I got
to see more um - his arm looked tired
towards the end of the year I'm not in
love with to a size or athletic ability
necessarily or his body type and I don't
think his arm his first round of
leanness and everybody out there don't
get it Jalen Hurst was 24 and two with
Alabama he can't throw alright so I but
so but - uh no he could be a successful
NFL player but I just don't see top-end
talent right now that would be my big
point and I he do I hear some people
going like oh he's a here's a future
first-round her you know no he was the
second best quarterback in that game the
other night for sure he plays small and
yeah I just need to see more in right
now if you made me make that assessment
I would go No - it is not a NFL
first-round quarterback I'm not sure
he's really a starting NFL quarterback I
would think he'd be more of a career
backup and that's what I thought it was
gonna be and for some reason I thought
it was [ __ ] Kyle Emery either way we'll
see where it goes and again what's wrong
to us I could have but Cuyler so you
really think he could be that
sensational so Kliff Kingsbury looking
in the camera and going he should be the
first pick in the draft he's that
special you see all those things pop
yeah I do even at five nine 190 right
we're talking we're talking three inches
smaller we're talking like 20 pounds
lives that would they say he is five
nine like five nine and a half I thought
he was like I thought they said it was
like five ten and a half or five eleven
either way no it's a different age in
the NFL he is been a quarterback for a
long time he knows how to see through
lanes just like Baker did and yeah I
think he's a special talent you have
told me before yeah that if your son who
have you solar instagram has
my own athletic ability for an
eight-year-old was gonna be venturing
into two sports baseball football yeah
you've told me you'd nudge him to
baseball I would like you these sensible
humans go you can get guaranteed money
in MLB but then your heart goes yeah
yeah but if I go to major league
baseball you're not gonna see me for
three years yeah I'm gonna be in Toledo
and Chico and Fresno and if I can't hit
the screwball then I might never get to
where I'm going you know but you could
always pull a drew Henson and you could
always play baseball for a while and
then come back and try and play football
but this kid you could tell loves
football loves you could tell that
that's his passion his hearts in
football and that's hard to go against
your heart and it's you know
quarterbacks not the type of position
you can go bass baseball at the bat back
the football we're not gonna do the Dion
you're not gonna do the bo Jackson we're
running backs and corners that were
reaction sports positions right my
question for you is yeah why is it that
there's this love of football like
you've been a high-profile athlete in
basketball baseball and football at the
high school level and then you chose
football what is it about football that
you can't get rid of that edge there's
something about the camaraderie the
locker room both and the other sport I
do think it is because of this reason
because it's one game a week and it's
that big and you're in it together and
there's just something about there's
nothing like hey listen I'm sure
baseball locker room a winning locker
room or the adrenaline you get when you
walk on the field and it's Texas
Oklahoma and you go whoa like baseball
is cool but holy crap we're going to
battle with this team and the fans are
about in a battle you're only gonna get
that in like the one game wildcard
playoff for Major League base it's a
Jordan Game seven of the World Series
it's a drug it's a really rug because
you go yes that feeling I just got the
chills talking about it I mean so for
you it's more of the fact that there's
less games and there's so much more
pressure on those moment right that the
moments are bigger than the other sport
is bigger you love first time I've heard
that and it makes a lot of you thrive in
it you know if you really love the sport
you just come that's why I'm playing I
went to Texas because I was like I want
to play in front of a hundred thousand
every week that's amazing like I can't
wait to do that even when we had like
north west south eastern and Missouri
State come to town the stadium was full
and I was like this is amazing to be a
part of I just got a phone call
yeah Schuyler and he said ask Sims what
his advice would be yeah so I'll pass it
along to him but I just tell our puck I
would say in my advice the caller Murray
would be to follow your heart
because if you don't follow your heart
you're always going to be
second-guessing yourself and going
you're not gonna be all-in on the other
on the thing that you're doing so if
your hearts and football and you're
trying to do baseball you're not gonna
be all-in on baseball I don't you can
fool yourself but at some point you're
gonna wake up one morning and go damn I
last 30 days in a row I've woke up
thinking about football and I'm sitting
here playing baseball why am i doing
that can you imagine knowing that you
had been a first-round pick of the NFL
Draft but you're on a bus in single-a
yeah right that's got to be and and it
was funny because when this happened
Oakland was like here's four and a half
million and it's like that's not that
much when he gets drafted in the first
round with the signing bonus and right
it's done right exactly right I mean he
can get more guaranteed money probably
at the top of the second round than that
right so yeah I mean again it's about
what he loves if he is yeah you know
again I haven't watched that's really
all I need it is really tiny but damn
you know he acres six foot like 215 220
it didn't look like that big of an issue
in the Alabama game you know they got
off to a little bit of a slow start but
once they got going it was uh-oh here we
go
do you think the fact that we have a
Patrick mahomes who was like a baseball
guy too and he turned down and had
success is like even motivating him
further I I'd it's so recent I think
that and they have like the same hair
right you're right I mean he's a ball of
muscle he is legit explosive hope 'tyler
yeah and his ability to throw is real
and you know what this is another thing
I'll say I'll give you a little food for
thought that I put stock into these type
of things
I heard Baker Mayfield talk about Cuyler
Murray about six weeks ago and he kind
of said like oh if you don't think Kyler
Murray's like super super talented freak
show then you're I don't know what
you're watching okay and you know he
said the same thing about Patrick Mahone
so he's not the kind of guy that throws
around
bullcrap comments like that What did he
say about Davis Webb though I don't know
he couldn't talk because he was
surrounded by binders his arm is so
strong so I was too strong maybe two all
right so you are you are you're a Kyler
Murray
it just goes to something that you've
always said it's when you watch a game
and someone jumps off the screen right
all the time he could probably play it
the next exactly right it just doesn't
seem to matter if it's a bad play a good
play whatever it is you just go well he
seems to make it work here here I was
ready for this fiery Kyler Murray taken
it was just him saying that Toa is gonna
be a career back up in the NFL which is
a very good take to well again if I'm
wrong I'll be the first one to go damn I
miss evaluated or whatever I don't get
back next year we develop a lot stronger
right fix a few things of this passing
mechanical one thing I want to say
before we get to these picks yeah the
the willingness of people in the media
and fans to write off an athlete at the
age of like 22 is is insane which is not
what we're doing here
what are you aiding him at this point no
what I'm what I'm saying though is like
when I went had that soccer phase when I
first started here and I was obsessed
with Everton they had this defender his
name was John I cameras name was like it
wasn't John snow but I'm just gonna say
John snow yeah and I was like this kid
sucks and I went on Twitter and like 80
people said dude he's 19 and he ended up
like having a good career after that but
it's like for people to go Lamar Jackson
can't do this right now yeah okay he's
the youngest quarterback to ever go to
the playoffs he's gonna develop you goof
right but if but Eli is not gonna
develop that's passed you know what I
mean right right how do you feel about
your picks how do you feel about your
four picks I feel pretty good I feel
good I mean I'm always a little nervous
about where I a lot the money but did
you lie to me at all yesterday not at
all first and told you everything very
much influenced my picks good okay I'm
not I'm just not smart enough to really
bull crap I can't remember my own
bullcrap or showed you because you lied
or stress
moving his money around yeah yeah all
right ready to get going here first game
of the weekend before 35 on Saturday the
Indianapolis Colts visiting the Kansas
City Chiefs
whether in Kansas City on Saturday
potential for snow accumulation less
than one inch chance of snow 50% keep
that in mind
right and you high that this is your
picks did you see it oh good yeah I
don't want to see spread in this game
Kansas City minus five and a half Sims
take it away
all right well I'm excited for that type
of weather for that football game I read
you're gonna be there yep when people
watch it I believe the pregame starts at
3 o'clock so let's do what we always do
take pictures of Sims and we're gonna
make captions if you want to take videos
of Sims we're gonna make fun of him too
yeah hopefully you [ __ ] up I'm letting
you know I usually root for you yeah I'm
hoping then you're like I forgot what I
was gonna say that's why I'm rooting for
that's what I did yesterday on the show
did you really yes I had to admit it I
was in the middle of a point and I was
like I forgot what I was gonna say I'm
gonna go to commercial if you can
accidentally call Florio left coach I
know you'd never do I'd appreciate so
yeah and I think I'm starting the game
from like inside the tunnel outside the
Colts locker like a walk and talk I
don't know what I'm doing but I know I'm
in a bunch of Secor they're gonna make
you be like and here outside the cheese
slot but I'm gonna get to see my homie
my homie my homie oh yeah are you doing
he throws I go throw no it's my buddy
you it's probably a little before your
time there but there was a rap song
called my buddy you're right I forgot
about that I thought that's what it was
no I'm he really going from the mob and
he's talking about his gun ever I go he
go he still stole that from I think the
doll that you know was my buddy as we
were growing up did you guys have my
buddy now and you didn't have Kennesaw
I've seen right that was a big deal when
I was growing up I never had one but
they were a big deal but beanie babies
beanie babies everywhere that all over I
remember that okay where should I start
here let's start with the Colts offense
verse the Chiefs defense okay you know
in a lot of ways hey we know the chief
defense is not that great to me the key
of the game is can the Chiefs get the
Colts to third down that would be a big
thing for that side of the ball the
Chiefs defense you know we've talked
about it all year that's where they can
be dangerous and do some off-the-cuff
things to confuse an Andrew Luck or a
Frank Reich and play calling situations
where I really worry about them is in
first and second down
no it's not a defense such ultra
talented we've discussed that a million
times their game is all about 95 55 and
50 ruining the football game it's gonna
be hard to do against the Colts okay and
the great wall of Indianapolis because
it's the best online in football it's
the best Oh wine left in this playoffs
and that's saying something because
there's a lot of good old lines left
because they're so young it's a wall
that Ballard really isn't have to pay no
he's gonna make Jim Irsay pay Borgia
Mercy's gonna try I guarantee it yeah
I guarantee it we didn't talk about this
last week her say drunk in the locker
room after the game was incredible look
I don't know how we didn't talk about
hey Quinn what him being like listen man
I'm so happy for you guys be like if you
guys could score like over 31 next week
I'd appreciate it but like honestly not
to make this all about me I'm happy and
I see potential in you I see I watched
muñoz okay it's not bad dude it's
spot-on pretty good [ __ ] spot-on it's
like I'm in my box and I'm ripping a
Marlboro and I'm like win good block man
so proud of you guys
that was amazing and I really enjoyed
watching Frank Reich just stand there
and like try to you know they're trying
to be the loyal soldiers but I'm sure
they were all like what where is he
going with this it was like watching a
best man speech yeah and Frank Reich was
the groom and he's like I shouldn't have
let this guy speak at my wedding yeah
like that's what it looked like I know
but he's the owner and a billionaire you
got to do that so but either way you
know hey I expect the Colts to be able
to move the ball on the Chiefs
especially when the emotions of the game
settle down that's going to be the big
thing for the Colts early on this is a
different Chiefs team they got Patrick
mahomes the fan base knows about all
their record with you know losing at
home you know I heard a cool stat today
you know the the Chiefs are 2 and 2 and
home playoff games and the Colts are 2
into 2 into it playing in in Kansas City
and playoff games but I think the big
thing is yes dealing with those early
emotions that crowd noise that will be
the toughest part for
the Colts early on now to flip it around
to the other side you know if anybody
listen to our deep-dive podcast that
we'd tape on Wednesday comes out
Thursday morning you know the one thing
I worry about with the Colts their front
7 they create a lot of chaos their speed
it's hard to run on them because they do
create a lot of chaos and you have to
sort out the blocking and when I say
sort out the blocking you know when
deepens align are slanting one way it's
hard for old-line to figure out how
they're going to block their particular
play when you know guys aren't exactly
where they thought they were going to be
but the biggest thing with the Colts and
their defense is of course you know
their secondary is not ultra talented we
know that it's just it's not a great
group they really build rely on scheme
being soundness not letting up big plays
all of those types of things
Kansas City especially if they have a
Sammy Watkins I think is going to be a
really tough matchup for this Colts
defense I think just like the Colts will
be able to slow down the Kansas City
pass rush I really expect Kansas City to
slow down the Colts pass rush as well
and the Colts pass rush is not as
talented as Chris Jones do you know
Houston and deep for it not at all if
I'm Kansas City you're not really a
running team so run to keep them honest
but the game is going to be one with
Patrick mahomes big right arm I really
envisioned this game and you see it I
really see Kansas City coming out and
jumping on them and like maybe going up
like 28 to 7 oh yeah that's what I think
could happen here but ha captain Andrew
will be calm in this manner and yeah I
think at the end of the day I'm betting
$10 ok on the Indianapolis Colts ok
just $10 but the big and I'm picking the
score to be 38 34 but as I said would be
the over but obviously right score 72
points right but I just I do I think the
emotions mahomes read with a week off is
going to have some plays especially
against a defense that doesn't do a lot
of stuff he's gonna have some new
wrinkles and I do I see it coming out
like 28 to 7 and then it's 28 to 4
and then it's 2821 and that it's 35:21
and there's 3528 and then you know
kansas city kicks a field goal to go up
3828 luck scores another touchdown late
and they got a kick onside kick to see
if they can win the game that's how I
kind of see a play now so the sorry 834
sorry you said it with the thing with
the Chiefs that everyone's bringing out
right now is there history of poor
performances at home in the play right
all time at home in the playoffs they're
two and seven now and they're two wins
we're during the first half of the 90s
and even in those two games the Chiefs
didn't cover the spread yeah they got
lucky to beat the pittsburgh steelers
with joe montana they are straight up
over their last 12 playoff games going
to january 1994 1 and 11 that is
straight up and against the spread and
that includes an owen six mark in home
games in that time now let's go and and
the thing that i wrote down is all of
these stats or trends are BPM before
patrick mahomes
that's exactly right so the pen the
thing is is I look at this the Chiefs
team that lost to the Titans last year
where they're up 18 I look at the Chiefs
team that lost to the Steelers a few
years ago where the Steelers didn't
score any touchdowns and the Chiefs
still lost we talked about all the wide
open receivers we saw in that game and
now exciteing row Alex Smith is your
quarterback right you are playing not to
lose yes when you have Patrick mahomes
as your quarterback you're playing it
takes on one soul right here's the
problem though the Chiefs in their last
five home games this year one in four
against the spread they have not been
beating teams by as much as they should
have been quite unquote right the last
five games what I did
oh so the other thing I looked up is
luck outdoor in the playoffs four
touchdowns nine interceptions in four
games only one game over 300 two of them
were I'm gonna say this okay two of them
were in New England thank you
one of them was in Baltimore one of them
was in Denver right and he beat Denver
and Peyton Manning think about how good
those defenses are that I just named
the Chiefs do not have that know and
those Colts are out man so that's right
what I did for all of these games pretty
much was what is the perfect game flow
for the Chiefs and what would be the
perfect game flow for the Colts and then
I thought in my head what's more likely
by the way I went back and watched that
Chiefs Raiders game and that pick six by
the Chiefs what the [ __ ] was Jared cook
- he must have thought it was a run play
when I watch that game I went while the
Raiders really did whatever they wanted
to but then like Josh like it's like
seven nothing yeah and and Derek Carr
throws it in the flat and Jared Cook is
looking at the sideline yeah and then
like the chief guy just takes to the
house and I was like okay so the Chiefs
were operating well but they weren't
beating the crap out of this team I just
want to see that yeah the perfect Colts
game flow mahomes start slow that they
stopped them on a third down early yeah
luck in the offensive line do what they
did to Houston were they're able to push
the ball down the field called get the
Colts game flow a lot of Marlin Mack
kind of set in the tone they're getting
the T Y Hilton play they're getting the
Ebron kind of working those guys and
they keep patty on the sidelines and
luck stays up that's a perfect game flow
if the Colts get the lead early it's a
battle back and forth the entire game
yeah the perfect Chiefs game flow was
Sammy plays because we don't know if
Sammy's playing yet I know Sammy could
be that surprised scratch Saturday
morning and all of a sudden we have no
idea he did practice can you look that
up he did yeah but just eliminate it's a
big key but the perfect Chiefs game flow
is Tyreke and Sammy are getting 40-plus
yard plays the Chiefs jump out to a huge
lead like you said rendering Marlon Mac
and the Colts running game useless and
that pass rush of the Chiefs gets to go
we get to come at glow in ski all the
time but when I wrote that down I wrote
in bold and parentheses I can still see
luck making a comeback
five and a half is too much with that
Chiefs defense I could see the Colts
winning this game
I don't have them winning this game
right I see more likely what you said
which is what I wrote in my notes yeah
chief spilled a lead and then luck gets
to go we're gonna do isolated matchups
and find a way to get back in this game
yeah the thing that scares me the most
there are very negative splits about
luck outside in the cold and T Y Hilton
outside in the cold but I also thinking
games like that the running game could
be a big thing and I trust Marlin Mac
and that offensive line more than I
trust Spencer where or whoever's or
Damian Williams and the Chiefs offensive
line I too will put $10 on the
Indianapolis Colts applause good that
that's a game where I think you're gonna
feel comfortable with the Chiefs you're
gonna be looking at and being like man
where I'm up 17 and then Luck's gonna
start coming back and you're gonna be
going stop them and you're gonna go I'm
relying on the Chiefs defense to stop
this team I don't think the Colts have
faced a passing offense like this all
year right but I wrote this down eibar
flus I have faith in in defensive
coordinator even lose more than I have
and Bob Sutton figuring out how to do
that there sure I don't think the Colts
defense is as passing defense is nearly
as bad as the Chiefs definitely not left
not even close
and so I'm kind of hoping the Colts are
gonna do a little specific game plan
take away Kelsey take away uh he'll I
mean of course they're gonna try to take
those away it's not in their DNA to
lease my evaluation at this point ok
please to take teams away because
they're not really a man-to-man zone -
that's what the issue is more than I'm
pulling for people in their zone exactly
right that's whatever flows could do
he's gonna find ways to flood the areas
he's got Kelsey slant right stop the
calcio over the middle and then don't
let Hill go deep right that's what
they'll try to do alright guys next game
8:15 on Saturday night to the Dallas
Cowboys visiting the Los Angeles Rams
whether in LA on Saturday rain in the
morning mmm chance of rain in LA in the
morning low track mostly cloudy at night
50 degrees is the low spread in this
game LA -
degrees the Rams might have to put snow
suits on um slow tracked favors to
Dallas Cowboys I'll just say that right
off the bat it's gonna definitely favor
the bigger team any time you have a
slower track like that so that will be
something to watch for okay
hey the Cowboys match up really well
with the Los Angeles Rams we know that
right okay if we just go to that side of
the ball there's a lot of things where
you look at and you go yeah you feel
good now there's gonna be a few things
to that you're not gonna feel too good
about all right you know the first thing
if we just go Rams offense first Cowboys
defense that's the marquee matchup you
know hey of course it scares me to death
that Shaun McVeigh had time off last
week we talked about that on the
Wednesday pod you know I would think
they spent two to three days on the
Cowboys because they had knowledge of
the other teams they might have had to
play you know the right I certainly
expect them to have some new plays and
new formations the Todd Gurley factor
how healthy is he as certainly a real
issue the offense goes through Todd
Gurley he is weapon number one he really
makes the pass game go the run game go
the screen game go he is that elite
factor in their offense where teams have
to tip their hand of what they want to
do because they're worried about him if
he's not a hundred percent that's an
issue of course I worry about the
interior Oh line against the Rams
against this cowboy front this cowboy
front is the real deal Holyfield they
have no weakness to their defense
there's none the only weakness you're
gonna get with the Rams is what we
talked about I mean the Cowboys defense
is what we talked about maybe being too
over aggressive oh it's a outside zone
to the left let's all fly over there get
Todd Gurley oh crap Jared Goff kept it
out the backside and there's a wide open
Robert woods coming across the formation
for an easy 20 yard game those are the
things that scare me you know you talk
about like uber flus I feel the same way
about the Cowboys they are a pretty good
zone team but the difference between
them and maybe a Colts team is they can
man you the F up they can man you up and
get in your face when they want to and I
don't know I don't think they're gonna
be very scared of woods and cook other
than game plan stuff that they know can
stress them out but I think like if it's
a static formation Byron Jones and
shidou Bay was a who's awesome
I mean there
both awesome I think they're gonna be
right in the face of woods and cooks I'm
gonna be like I don't think you guys
could run by us I think that's the way
they could play in some certain
situation fact that you think Sean
McVeigh is gonna line up cooks in a
static formation isn't so well I mean he
could in certain times we yeah we'll see
it's just something to watch out for yes
McVeigh is gonna do his best always to
get cooks off that's what he does so yes
they're certainly gonna be easy
completions for Kutcher at some point
during the game
now to flip it around to the other side
and like I said we got to make sure we
get to that I am always worried about 65
and 66 on the interior offensive line
for the Los Angeles Rams especially on
third down when all the sudden DeMarcus
Lawrence is inside and Tyrone Crawford
is outside they have so many good pass
rushers the the the Dallas Cowboys how
about Malik Collins coming back and
being so impactful yes Seattle game I
know that was a name where I was like
I've been staring at him on the injury
list for so long this year and to see
him come back in there he was a huge
game record he's a game wrecker
Antoine Woods is a very good user to I
mean I'm very good at finding that body
type right they really are you're
exactly it's a rod marinelli key and and
of course the linebackers in the middle
are gonna be very tough on Gurley and
the screen game and all that
now to get to the other side of the ball
Dallas okay yeah I worry again Wade
Phillips he's I would think gonna have a
few things up his sleeve as well I worry
if Dallas got behind like 14 nothing
early I think that could be trouble
ville okay because I mean Dallas is just
not made to be in shootouts and dak
Prescott has been playing really good
that continues the way he's throwing the
football hanging in the pocket all of
that I am most concerned about one thing
Connor Williams on Aaron Donald that is
my biggest issue of this football game
and that's what's scary of Billy Madison
playing dodgeball in kindergarten I mean
it's a it's a scary aspect right there
Connor is certainly the weak link and
they are going to have to do things to
help him out if they can in certain
scenarios or try to avoid Aaron Donald's
side of the ball or whatever that may be
okay
I think the Cowboys will run the ball on
this defense but I think because of the
Cowboys
lack of imagination in the past game
it's going to allow the Rams to maybe
put a little more eggs in the let's stop
the run basket right I do see that
happening and when you have a bunch of
you know hey they got a bunch of badass
mofos on that side of the defense - you
know that they're they're gonna be keyed
in on Ezekiel Elliott but I do worry
about the Cowboys just mashing that Rams
d-line downhill smaller linebackers mark
Baron Littleton I do worry about that
but at the end of the day I'm going with
the team that's been the most consistent
through the year okay
and I'm I am going with the Rams the
Rams are going to win this football game
but I am betting 790 790 dollars on the
Dallas Cowboys to cover this spread I
will be shocked my feet might still be
on the ground but we're gonna ride him
um but um you would be shocked if I
would be shocked if the Rams blew them
out that's Riley be shocked I won't be
shocked if either team wins the football
game if Dallas won the game I'm not
gonna be like one of the funniest things
you ever said right well you know what I
wouldn't be shocked if either team on
the football well you know what I mean I
mean I won't be shocked if the Cowboys
without you that's what I mean to say
but I would be wrong in fact I bet that
one where can i buy that vent
so I'm picking the Rams to win 24 to 23
I think the Rams are gonna be losing in
this game 23 21 and golf and company are
gonna make a late fourth quarter drive
so when to kick a game-winning field
goal the Cowboys are gonna get the ball
back to have a chance to go down and
Aaron Donald's gonna get a sack fumble
and the game will be over so I just have
my stream-of-consciousness I'm just
gonna go through this first thing I
looked at was wow the Cowboys beat the
something's coming here I just know it
cuz Josh I know both of your poker face
that's true the Cowboys
three and five on the road the city went
7-9
the Rams I don't know yet Cowboys were
three and five on the road this season
and the reason I looked that up was they
beat the Saints at home and we have all
we have all these memories the Seattle
Seahawks we have all the memories of how
a good Dallas is at home but we forget
the games on the road
oh dak was so good against the Giants
guys they let up 30-something points to
the Giants on the road they lot they let
up 23 points to the Colts and play like
crap on the road there are a different
team on the road yeah Dallas to me is
that emotional team that your dad talked
about they get super high at home and
motivated and they came out that way
last week and I don't know if they're
that great at the everyone's betting
against us
they're really like the everywhere
America's Team right I also looked it up
which is I'm what I'm betting they're
feeling like I got you that's quite
another thing just really [ __ ] us he
interrupts me an owner up oh I just
wanted who do you think have more fans
there at the game oh that's a good point
probably Dallas probably does yeah good
Dallas has 39 sacks this season 26 of
them were at home yeah so they only had
13 sacks on the road which I think is
the key to Dallas winning this game
I wrote down if Jared Goff is having
shitpants day it's over
Dallas is winning this game if it's
Jared Goff like looking at the rush and
like falling back and throw when this
game is over yeah and and that's the
scariest thing so that's why I looked
that up I looked it up the last few row
games for the Cowboys Giants led up all
those points Colts lost 23 to nothing
Falcons their offense put up 22 points
Eagles kind of those late plays or
whatever there were three and one but
all they were it was not the same Dallas
teen that we've seen at home the Rams
over their past six games against teams
that made the playoffs this year against
the spread oh five and one hmm oh five a
woman OC you're going all Cowboys here I
don't know I lost this time I don't like
being I wrote this and I had it in bold
I have a few things in bold with this
game I felt very confident about this
game the Rams are not going to be afraid
of pressing the wide receiver
of the Cowboys and I think when you were
telling me about the simplicity of the
offense
I think Wade's gonna go we're gonna stop
the run and I feel very confident
putting a keep to leave or Marcus Peters
on Amari Cooper the true thing is is
like sure my cup gal Michael gallop
catches a touchdown but like are you
really afraid of Michael gallop beating
you for an entire game and not valid
points um the other thing I thought was
I went back and watched Rams Niners cuz
I didn't watch any of that game yeah and
they were playing like people possessed
like that defense against the Niners
where we kind of thought they were like
Aaron down elbows in the backfield send
in balls straight up in the air and it
made me think this if Aaron Donald gets
a sack that Cowboys drive is rendered
useless that drive is over if it's
second and 17 the drive is over if also
the other thing I thought was I'm trying
to save some of my points for the end
here but I just I just think that Aaron
Donald's gonna like they're they're
teeing off I think they're the they're
the most disrespected team that's
currently alive of the eight they're the
forgotten team with the by right right I
also thought that the Cowboys struggled
a little bit on the road versus Indiana
with a wide receiver with speed in T Y
Hilton and they haven't really faced a
lot of wide receivers with speed I
thought Tyler Lockett got off a little
bit less you have your opportunity I
think that cooks and then we're gonna
have some opportunity I love Lockett got
70 yards on one play this is my first
road playoff game for dak and Zeke
they've played in the playoffs and
they've played well but both of those
games have been at home in fact I went
back it's the only road playoff game for
almost the entire team except for the
dez catch game yeah and they weren't
really that great in that game either
here I'm our perfect game flows a
perfect Cowboys game flow cards are an
issue Jared Goff has hit early and often
Gurley looks slow and rusty and cannot
run out run those Dallas linebackers and
they're able to control the game with
Zeke
rams cannot stop that running game no
matter what and they're able to catch
Marcus Peters a few times with Cooper
over the top that's the perfect Cowboys
game right the perfect Rams game in my
mind is misdirection and a lot of
different place to get Dallas all over
the place they do what we've been saying
teams do when they have success against
Dallas and they spread them out
McVeigh gives Goff a lot of easy
completions early in the game to get
them comfortable they get a little bit
of lead Cowboys stop running and then
Aaron Donald and Dominic ensue get to
high-five and go it's your turn to take
a shot at Connor Williams I went back
and looked and I wanted to say I feel
like I've been on the Cowboys the last
six weeks I'm for one and one in picking
Cowboys games the one game I lost was
the Eagles game because I was hoping the
Eagles were gonna beat the Cowboys that
game I look at this game of all the four
and it's the only matchup where I go
even if one team if one team's up big I
don't see the other team coming back if
the Chiefs are up big on the Colts Colts
can still come back and obviously the
other way around if the Chargers are up
big on the Patriots they're gonna find a
way and we've seen the Chargers come
back multiple times
I could see Nick Foles leading a
comeback I could see Drew Brees leading
a comeback but if the Rams are up 14
nothing the Cowboys are dead to rights
and because of that I'm putting fifteen
hundred and seventy on the Los Angeles
Rams oh my god I love it so many holes
in your theory I saw so many holes in my
theory but here's the main reason I'm
doing yeah I have such an advantage in
the coaching matchup yeah in Sean
McVeigh and Jason Garrett with one week
off I am absolutely afraid what you said
if the Cowboys jump up to a lead I would
tear my ticket on my couch and at
halftime I'm going to say I'm [ __ ]
thanks for coming I am playing a
gambling game with you I can't do 400 on
every game I need to find a
market inefficiency where I can attack
and get a huge lead yeah and I believe
that taking a home team against a very
simple team with a Rams team that has
speed and I also believe has more elite
players yeah when I was I don't know
about that I understand what I'm saying
like this but when I I wanna lead guys
on this field I also just I look at this
Cowboys team and I can see a deflation
possibly coming but the other thing that
really got me was watching that Rams
Niners game and watching how the Rams
handled turnovers it's they are an
aggressive team yeah and if a keep Talib
or Marcus Peters or one of those
linebackers take something to the house
Dallas could be dead Dallas could be
done because then it's dak sitting back
there trying to throw the whole time I
just it's the only matchup where I went
if it goes my way early it's over could
be certainly good big right now poke
holes in my theory and are you are you
scared are you excited that I made this
bet I actually feel really good about
this one yeah yeah I think where you go
Josh how do you feel I think it's great
content I steered at this direction Josh
was winking at me the entire time no I I
mean you know hey listen
Jared golf was the issue by day loss
last year so that's a question mark the
biggest we'll see right you know what I
mean the fact I'm betting on my
doppleganger scares the grippe I think
Dallas is a front running team and they
feel like they're indestructible right
now so that's just the way they're but
do you see what I'm saying where it's
like if Aaron Donald creates havoc that
the front-runner turns into fear I
immediately I get you now your 49ers
point O brands are playing something
49ers weren't they put the Cardinals
before that all right my other thing
this would be probably one of the
biggest things why I just can't imagine
it being a blowout with big hulking
teams the Rams struggle at all year and
that's what the Cowboys are the Eagles
the Bears the games against the Seahawks
were closed because they couldn't stop
the running game so that's what I worry
about but it is playoff football and
it's gonna be a little different and
they've had extra time to prepare so
maybe they do things last thing I would
say to is they just haven't been playing
a lot of man-to-man lately but I listen
left go
I mean we've also seen
do stupid things and some big moments
not being able to put a team away or
dominating early like the Tennessee
Titans game he threw the right and threw
two interceptions why they running like
the five-yard line so those are all
scary I mean I really know what to say I
don't agree with you but well I felt I
felt the most confident because what you
say score I didn't do a score huh i I
nice burp Thanks it's to me it's the
Shawn McVeigh it's it's we're in this
coaching cycle where if you've been
around Shawn McVeigh you got a head
coach and he's had like three weeks he's
rested Todd Gurley all this time even
though that kind of backfired last year
in the playoffs I just have to imagine
that Shawn McVeigh is gonna go I know
what the weaknesses of my team are yeah
and I can find a way to manipulate this
defense sure am i confident I'm not that
confident but I'm not confident in any
four of these games I think I think any
team can win any four of these games it
was just the one game where if it went
my way early because I just think Dallas
can pack it in yeah all right guys let's
move on Sunday thirteen hundred and
sixty no no no 2361 game that's where we
are
all right guys Sunday if your comment
about the hulking teams though is
undoubtedly the thing that scares up but
you're right but again your McVeigh
point about he's had a week off and try
to figure out his own weaknesses and
what they wanted to do to hide those
that's you were just so disappointed in
the Cowboys game planning last week yeah
that and I almost think it as a positive
is really probably the thing that
because I think they're gonna look at
that game and go we won and we got to do
more this week and we didn't even play
our best last week or so we'll say well
you would know Jason Garrett and his
philosophy more than me I feel like they
said we were up ten with 80 seconds left
we had that game we were fine right and
we were able to push around Seattle yeah
have they ever faced Aaron dot yeah they
did the rams went into last year yeah
yeah all right sunday 1:05 the charger
visiting the Patriots weather and
Foxborough on Sunday talk about it
ooh am clouds p.m. Sun high of 29
degrees low of 17 I was on a weather
website this morning looking mainly at
the Chiefs Colts and the Chargers
Patriots right and it looks so cold for
the Patriots came like like bitter like
like it was to the point where I'm
reading weather reports are like if
you're a fan it might not be best to go
to this game and I was like that's
awesome spread I love watching football
like that New England - for New England
- for all right um I guess we'll start
out what side should I start out with
left go start off with the Tom Brady
versus the Chargers defense okay that's
the better matchup it is the better yeah
you're right it's the problem it is the
better matchup the Chargers they line up
in the same defense almost all game long
they might change a little personnel out
here or there but they all line up in
the same spot about 95 percent of the
time okay that's that I look at that
aspect of it first of all and that
scares me for the Chargers a little bit
just because I just go damn it's you
know Josh and Bill and they've had extra
time to tinker with this and they found
ways to you know screw Seattle and and
that team and the Super Bowl so they
have great understanding of the defense
in general the the run game for the
Patriots that's where it starts
everybody the Patriots are running
football team so it's not about Brady
and Gronk it's really about running the
football and that they can have success
there that's where we'll start to see
the success of Brady Gronk and Edelman
from there the Chargers are undoubtedly
the faster team on the field when it's
their defense first a Patriots offense
now the differences between the the run
game of the Patriots and let's say the
Ravens do last week first of all the
Patriots are a big football team as well
but their old line is not like Baltimore
no it's big but their interior old
linemen are more athletic based they're
kind of stout athletic based guys is it
fair to say that trait Trent Brown makes
us think their offensive line is big
because he's so mad exactly but the rest
but like their Center like is not big at
all yeah
no he's not it's not real big no and
Shack Masons just like a compact he's a
fire hydrant he's a fire hydrant right
now to your Trent Brown point huge man I
do worry about it because it was speed
he's a little bit slow and foot and I
mean we talked about Melbourne Ingram
having the game of his life last weekend
and Joey Bosa I mean they're freaks of
nature that's where the game plan will
start from New England like we said on
Wednesday the first thing they were
going to do is go how do we not let
Ingram and Bosa ruin the game so that's
where it goes from there and then they
build out from there I do think that the
Patriots run game even though looking
more traditional is more advanced and
we'll run into better looks that they
want to run the ball into then let's say
a Baltimore Ravens so I think they're
gonna have enough success running the
ball that's gonna put the Chargers in a
bind and then the big thing that's a
difference between the Patriots run game
and the Baltimore run game as the
Patriots have a plethora of play-action
passes off of that and the Patriots are
the kings of slowing down fast defenses
with wide receiver screens and running
back screens and all those things to
take away that natural aggressiveness so
I see that being a factor in there
I do think German James can match up
against a Gronk and big situations a
man-to-man and give them time I think if
this you know if they get to third and
six or seven it's advantage Chargers
that'll be a big t8 third and six or
more will be advantaged Chargers because
of the pass rush and because I think
they can cover New England New England
has deficiency is a receiver Edelman's
not the same guy Gronk's not the same
guy
Chris Hogan's not the same guy the
Chargers will be able to play man if
they want to dabble in that which they
don't like to live in it but they will
dabble um now to flip it over to the
other side
cold weather Phillip Rivers arm has
looked weak lately we talked about on
the Wednesday podcast that the I thought
the Chargers receivers have looked slow
for the last few weeks my theory is that
they run a lot of deep routes all year
long and practice and their legs have
finally caught up to them and they're
tired love that theory there's a random
they are a ton they're the Patriots you
know I'm sitting here looking at the
team
now other than the Cowboys the Patriots
have the best secondary I think left as
far as just pure cover man-to-man type
guys right that's funny I know I mean
because JC Jackson is a budding star and
Stephon Gilmore is one of the best
corners in football and then you got the
two McCourty twins Devin Jason
Jason's the nickel guide Evans the
safety and I think we think he's healthy
right yeah I worry about like I said on
the Wednesday podcasts about okay we
don't first all Melvin Gordon that's
gonna be an issue is he gonna be healthy
ready to go because they need to run the
ball to keep the Patriots honest a
little bit I worry about the Chargers
offense in general because it is
sputtered down the stretch it really has
sputtered I mean they were outplayed in
the last week last game of the year
against the Denver Broncos they were
outplayed they were just fortunate to
win that game really
the Broncos screwed it up if you go back
and watch it the Broncos really kind of
dominated the game in the first half the
the other thing yeah so I worry about
them being that way oh and then the
other thing is this you know I worry
about Eckler I'm third and six plus
because right the big linebackers all of
those things how do the Patriots match
up against the receivers is something
everybody needs to watch because when it
becomes third and six plus I'm just
intrigued and I don't know the answers
to these let's just talk it out like
what are they gonna do how are they
gonna match up I would imagine it would
go JC Jackson Mike Williams or Keenan
Allen I was i mike williams i think he
would go my boy he's really good with
big physical guys like what he did to
juju was fan I think that's exactly and
then I think they look at Mike is there
50/50 right so I think that could be
Gilmour or JJC and Gilbert big guys
right you know what I mean so I think
you're faster though I don't know it's
close I feel like either of them would
give Keenan Allen a shitload of problems
I think the size thing though at least
in my and you might be right I don't
know here I'm trying to talk it out
almost in my own way here I would think
they'd go JC and Gilmore on the to
Williams and then I imagine them going
Chung McCourty or mobility twins on
Keenan in any certain situation because
though you know you know the Patriots
really well
they love to double the main guy and put
their better guys on - and I think so I
don't even say I wanna waste their best
guys on a guy that doesn't really go
deep Perkins and I have led up big plays
the key now is the middle of the field
option good route right yeah let Chun be
physical right cordial admin exactly
McCord he can cheat on the other guy
they can in and out them do all those
things so that will be the element I
watch yeah for people that haven't been
listening to us for a number of years
Sims would say during the Darrelle Revis
Patriots years that when Brandon browner
was good and yeah not committing crime
right that they would put him and sort
of shade a safety to the number one
receiver and then use Revis to
completely erase the number two yes
because if it's all number one a lot of
teams are gonna game plan for that and
focus on the number two right but then
when you look over and go damn yeah this
is on our number two right so the
Patriots have always done that yeah yeah
there are the masters of that so that
will be a something to watch out for for
sure at the end of the day I am putting
$10 on the New England Patriots that
means seven ninety is only the the
Saints or the go sacks wicked-hot child
are just don't like chow table going
Patriots 23 17 so it's really funny is
when Rivers lost to New England in the
plate playoffs
it was 2112 when they lost last year in
that game it was 2113 you're right so
right around there you're right in the
same place I went back and watch last
year's game yeah Chargers didn't fall
for anything
Anthony Lynn and their coaching staff
and Gus Bradley you're good they had it
diagnosed and it was perfect man there
were some big plays in that game you had
Melvin Gordon with an 80 plus yard
touchdown run to give the Chargers a
seven nothing lead I
you had Travis Benjamin getting a safety
on a punt return which turned into five
points because the Patriots got a field
goal after that Dion Lewis had a huge
kickoff return to start the second half
gave the the Patriots the ball like in
the 40 of the Chargers and Malcom Butler
at the end of the game when the when the
Patriots were up like like 11 or 12 got
burned on a touchdown that the Chargers
had but the Chargers did not get their
offense going the entire game
they couldn't get Melvin Gordon going
philip rivers couldn't get anything
going the Patriots had the Chargers
numbers on offense then to write hatreds
really dominated that game
good job going back to that and I kind
of fur all this time thought the
Chargers dominated but really it was
just a few big plays that made me think
that since that last game though I think
the Chargers defense is a lot better
there was no term when James back then I
think the Chargers offensive line is
much better I think that the Chargers
running backs and wide receivers though
are a lot more banged up I think Mike
Williams is more seasoned but Benjamin
had speed in that game yeah and I don't
I haven't seen that a number of weeks to
what you're saying I also think the
Patriots weapons are a lot worse there's
no more Dion Lewis Gronk did not look
the way he does now the way he did then
yeah right Chris Hogan was firing on all
cylinders yeah I could see Chris Hogan
making a comeback
sure Rex Burkhead looked a lot better
there but I would also say the Patriots
secondary is a lot better the Chargers
on the road this year have been dominant
away from home lately not only have they
been seven and OH straight up and
against the spread in row games since
the start of October they've outscored
their opponents on the road by an
average of 10 points per game
over the seven contests winning by an
average score of 27 to 17 I looked it up
Tom Brady at home in the divisional
round of the playoffs is 11 and 1
they've won seven in a row by an average
of 17 points only losses what the Jets
Rex Ryan that was the eighth game yeah
but they're in the stretch the closest
game of those 7 straight wins was for to
the Ravens hmm and that's our spread in
this game yeah difference between this
Chargers team that Ravens team is I
believe the Chargers are faster than
that Ravens team I believe the Ravens
were more physical than this Chargers
team and I also thought they had a coach
that wasn't afraid to do crazy stuff
Anthony Lin is a coach to me that would
rather play it by the book say we're
more physical than do a crazy play
I agree I don't think that's good
because I think the Patriots are gonna
do a flea-flicker in this game I think
they're gonna do an Edelman pass they
know they're not as talented as the
Chargers bella checks about to throw it
all out there I he's gonna do what I
always do he's gonna do what Saban did
in the championship game except it's
gonna be good plays because Belichick
expects to be the slower team in the
field sometimes I think savings like let
me just make sure that we can't just
push around Clemson Bellatrix like I'm
not that crazy
here I'm our perfect game flows the
perfect Chargers game flow is Ingram
Bosa are getting around the edge and
they're getting after Brady and they're
getting some three and outs early the
secondary is not afraid of the Patriots
weapons they get right up there they're
jamming because really Mike Davis should
not be afraid of Edelman Derwin James
should not be afraid of grunt now who's
the wide receiver that you should be
afraid of for the Patriots right the
only one that I'm afraid of is the the
James White's of the world and sort of
some misdirection where Darryl Cordero
yeah Rivers works Gordon and the white
Gordon yeah Melvin Gordon and the wide
receivers and they're deep shots and
5050 balls to Benjamin and Mike Williams
hit that's the perfect game flow for the
Chargers perfect game flow for the
Patriots is they keep the Chargers
pass-rush
off-balance there's trick plays and
misdirection and they also establish the
run and the Chargers are sitting there
going
they've hit us early with misdirection
and now they're pounding us in the face
with Sony Michele and we can't tee off
on it Rivers is under pressure make some
mistakes where if you're gonna be honest
he's made a lot of mistakes early in
games the offensive weapon for the
Chargers just aren't able to make plays
and when I thought about it and I
thought about the Tom Brady being 11 and
1 at home in the divisional round and
the fact that it's gonna be in the 20s
in New England and the the Chargers are
feeling high after beating up the Ravens
I'm going with the Patriots and I'm
putting $10 on the Patriots - for just
because when I look at the Patriots it's
a collection of good decisions
it's the field goal at the end of the
first quarter and the field goal T into
the third quarter and Anthony Lin
thinking he's got to go for it and at
the Patriots forty on fourth and one
that over time puts Phillip Rivers in a
hole and he's got to come back but the
difference between a Chiefs whole and a
Patriots whole is that the Patriots also
get those little points where the hole
is 14 right and it's and they're
dropping back and they know exactly what
you want to do I also think it's really
giving you credit you were one of the
first people saying that the Patriots
secondary is really good and I think
that the the Chargers really rely on
just outclassing your secondary and I
think they're outclassed
so I'm putting $10 on the Patriot
alright alright guys moving on the
Philadelphia Eagles on the road visiting
the New Orleans Saints whether in New
Orleans New Orleans Saints whether in
New Orleans just in case you care 56
degrees partly cloudy on Sunday spread
in this game is New Orleans - 8 Cris ok
here we go alright let's go back to Game
one ok let's do this real quick alright
I'm just letting you I did not watch
that game ok I did so that's good
here we go we're a team um okay I'm just
gonna rattle off stuff here right okay
cuz I wrote notes in my phone and that's
texting to your wife I did wifey wife
he's got a lot of football text she
probably getting off she's taking
horseback riding lessons right now she's
probably getting off going home why is
this she's been doing that yes she
wanted to be able to ride with Charlotte
so they're they're doing horseback
riding gosh okay here we go
thoughts I'm just gonna throw them all
out there first of all at the first
meeting
the Eagles couldn't even line up on
defense okay I mean that was no common
theme throughout the whole game the
Saints snapping the ball and the Eagles
looking at each other going they're
doing this the whole game and they're
like oh yeah
whoever I got him Irwin what the hell is
it so many bad moments like that you
know again the Eagles are healthier now
right you look at that part of it and go
they've made tweaks with their personnel
or trace Ullman's out there Jernigan
zout there so now I have to play nada
very much anymore because nada was a
huge weakness in that football game okay
LeBlanc had just got there that's so
funny that nada was a weakness he was a
weakness you know it's over for naught
yeah yeah he's just sad I know it is sad
cuz he was such a big hulking I hope
people understand how good he was the
beginning of all - no no doubt about it
I'm just Fletcher I see him in his first
game ever starting in the NFL and I
remember going to the center he was one
of those guys where when I would get
underneath the center I would go can my
center actually snap me the ball and
still block him he looked like a guy
that if you looked across a line his
face filled the entire helmet look like
it was like too much because I was -
[ __ ] scared of Ray Lewis that was three
feet behind him where I was not realest
and that's why he didn't look at it okay
Suggs and Chris McAllister man that deep
is good okay
LeBlanc had just got there try Sullivan
wasn't even playing at safety yet okay
now Josh I know right Avante Maddox he
got hurt early on in that football game
and he wasn't what he was then as he is
now okay the Saints whooped the crap out
of the Eagles that was one of the I mean
obviously the scores showed that but I
had but I don't I'm not even more about
the score the Eagles I don't know girl
ran all over them it was they got beat
up worse than that game that I can ever
remember at any game through a two-year
stretch now the reason that all the
major media networks were going is just
the worst Super Bowl team in the second
year ever
right because we'd never seen them but
there was a lot of moving parts there so
that was an issue okay
um they lost that battle up front um
where do I want to go here okay
Fletcher Cox Fletcher Cox probably had
one of his worst games I've ever seen
him have he got pushed around like a
number of times the other thing to take
into a food account to let me food to
account Oh food to account yeah into
account or food for thought these are
double I have another one cuz I just
looked it up yeah I was going to
I'm looking at the snap counts Jason
Kelsey played six snaps in that game
they had to play Wisniewski andsome Melo
at Center you were gonna say that's
where I was going so there was injuries
you guys were not the same team that's
the first thing you have to say added to
the fact you just came off a slugfest
with the Dallas Cowboys and the Saints
just came off a scrimmage versus the
Bengals okay so they were fresh you guys
were beaten down and again everybody
goes through their peaks and valleys of
the season the Saints were at that time
they were rolling right roll it was
rolling it was like damn they're just
mowing down everybody in their path that
was obviously the worst part of your
football season as a Philadelphia Eagle
you guys were in the lowest of the
valleys you've been in in the Doug
Peterson era okay
the Eagles oh not as diverse
then as it is now you're doing more the
pike calling I don't know if it's the
Doug Peterson factor like we talked
about Tate had just got there they
haven't really figured that out Darren
Sproles of course was not out there I
was talking to my dad about this last
night right and it made me have a theory
Doug Peterson was applauded last year
for working so much with DeFilippo and
Frank Reich and and sort of having this
offensive room where it was like a
commingled assortment of offenses and I
really think that losing Frank Reich so
late in the process and then also losing
D filippo and promoting grow and do
stalee into those positions art I think
Doug Peterson went we're gonna do the
same thing grow duce were all gonna do
it together
right I don't know if you agree with me
but watching Doug on the sidelines these
last few weeks yeah it's Doug's offense
right III think so I feel like he looked
at those and went Frank Reich was an OC
for years T Filippo was an OC in
Cleveland and I'm giving these guys that
have not called plays as much respect as
them right and I feel like Doug took it
all back yeah that's my fear with what
happened this you think that would be my
theory as well I don't know exactly when
that happened I think it happened
sometime here in the last month right to
where it just changed around and I mean
we've been talking about the play
callings change a little bit all of
those things so so there's that
okay now
um you know listen the defense just fell
apart the football game there's no other
way to say it
you know it's 17 to 7 okay just what I
wanted you and you guys you're at the
midfield point still being dominated
having a chance to stay in the game
fourth and six he throws a deep ball
that's uncatchable that was that was
even before this so it's that's already
happened all right
that's already happened so well you it's
72 seven and they they have fourth down
at midfield I'm going the Eagles are in
this game yes it's right that's the
fourth down in midfield and he's got an
open receiver and uh if I just want to
make sure I got this right I think it
was once kind of missed the snap I was
at that point no no I'm wrong that was
later in the game I can't remember how
they missed this fourth down I think he
has an open receiver and he gets hit as
he's throwing it and the ball doesn't go
where he wants to I'm sorry I got so
many damn plays in my head either way I
know there was there to be had as I
watched the game I said there was some
people open I'm not saying for like
bombs but they could have executed the
offense but it was always a mistake
somebody's open I'll once gets hurts
right as you throw it or you know
somebody's open again and just the whole
pocket collapses whatever it may be
there was all it was a very poorly
played football game by the Philadelphia
Eagles uh okay so let me just make this
up so now it's 17 to 7 ok they're at
midfield I wrote this down thank God all
right
Oh line got dominated two plays in a row
Saints got the ball went down and made
it 24 7 cuz your demons couldn't do
anything
halftime get the ball back touchdown 31
exactly right you guys got the ball with
30 seconds left and a half backed up you
didn't do anything they got the ball
back now so now you were down 17 7 and
the next time the Eagles offense came on
the field it was 31 to 7 game over
checkmate see ya gotta go so that was
that I think that's the thing I look at
it's not even fair to really even say
that's the same Eagles team it's just
not I the Eagles have figured out what
they want to do offensively we talked
about the injuries the health matters
all of that but it's still the Saints
and they're at home and they are the
most complete team in football and
there's no weaknesses and that's where I
look at this game so at the end of the
day he's loading up on the sage going
790 dollars
fly fly
go fight Eagles fight fight for Eagles
fight for Chris Sims cuz he wants to
read with Adam Adam Adam Adam well the
good thing is I have so much in the Rams
game that that's really what its gonna
say I know but I know it's hoping you
were gonna be like with me or against or
what your scores I'm going Saints 28
goals 24 so it's still an eagle's loss
it is an eagle's loss sorry eel stance
yeah but you feel it's gonna be close
who's gonna jump out ahead um I would
think you got your game flow like what's
your predicted game flow I think the
Eagles will jump out I think the Eagles
are gonna come out you know this is what
I always worry about the team on the by
who hasn't played at the end of the
regular season one team's been in a bar
fight for the last five weeks and been
like put your dukes up we're going
outside and get a fight and the other
team has been like man we're so awesome
we don't have to fight in these bar
fights I'm just gonna sit how are you
guys figure it out and I'll fight the
champion cuz I'm over here sipping pina
coladas to that and that worries me
that's my I reacted on Wednesdays
podcast to the Sean Payton 225 with fear
and I thought about it last night and
it's completely turned in my mind why
because I watched interviews with Mark
Ingram and Sheldon Rankin's
talking about how great of a motivator
Sean Payton is he really knows how to
like push all our buttons and get ready
and I'm sitting there and I'm going Wow
Sean Payton just told them that we're
going for a Super Bowl the Eagles are
going they [ __ ] are looking past us
they're looking at the [ __ ] Super
Bowl right if I was Doug Peterson I'm
bringing 225 thousand dollars into the
locker room and I'm setting it on fire
last year Super Bowl trophy and I'm
setting them I'm setting the money on
fire
don't ever set that much money on fire
I'm saying well somebody will beat his
ass and that I Fletcher Cox might go
over to Doug Peterson back hey coach
you're a bit crazy I just think if like
if I'm
into like if I was Sean Payton the
motivator right I'm bringing two I'm
bringing a box like I saw the Cavaliers
when they won the championship right
they had a puzzle and it was each time
you get a win you had a piece to the
puzzle in the end the puzzle was the
Larry O'Brien trophy and isn't that
wonderful if I'm Sean Payton I'm taking
25,000 I'm putting in a box I'm going
you win this game you get 25k I just
like looking at the players and they're
like we're just ready to make a run and
we're ready to do all this stuff and it
was actually so beneficial because the
Eagles get to sit there and go more
underdog they think they're winning the
Superbowl they're not even thinking
about you and I think that the Eagles or
they could even take it as they're
scared and look they're trying to
motivate I mean right right I just I
came away from that and I was like you
know what the Eagles are the barfight
team yes the Eagles are the like if
you're in a dogfight are the Saints
gonna be sitting there going guys we got
to play for 225,000 like it's not really
gonna motivate them later
no like they're like they're gonna be
sitting there being like [ __ ] we were
supposed to win the Superbowl and the
Eagles are going I'm winning this play I
don't know am I crazy is that too much
food it's not there is it all those
emotions could be very real here I mean
these are all hypotheses we don't know
where it could go certainly III get that
but no it's not fans speak those are
real emotions that are gonna run get
hired you feel if you were an eagle and
you heard the 225 Lombardi's yeah I
would have turned it into like kind of
something like I said like look guys
they're there got to find extra
motivation to play us well that's what
Doug Peterson said right he said the
playoffs for motivation enough exactly
so that's right motivates his player
apparently with ice cream that would I
if I would jug Peterson I'd be going hey
listen you know that was cool Sean
Payton did that all that we know that
we're not afraid to fight anybody I mean
that's all we used to talk about last
year and a brawl in the NFL
the Eagles definitely would have been
the last team standing and just
fistfights like we're gonna all do a 32
dot there Big Lake jump off Fletcher Cox
Brandon Brooks what about Doug Peterson
right I'm playing it off going look at
this guys Sean Payton scared the other
thing is is I said this at the end of
the podcast yesterday I'm gonna say it
today
I have become Saints public enemy number
one
if Eagles win this game yeah I promise
to the Sims and left go fans I will be
ruthless if the Eagles lose it's gotta
get it's gonna get really bad to the
point where I got this tweet from let's
bharden with it if that does happen next
week well cuz here's why we're gonna
need to mark Stevens 21 underscore
tweeted at me 41 minutes ago I mean this
in complete seriousness don't step foot
in this city don't slander my
quarterback we will in all capital
letters stab you I just got that on
Twitter 40 minutes ago is that like
doesn't Twitter police and that stuff
the thing that I'm trying to say is no a
lot of threatened people bailed out all
the fan bases in the NFL I have said
crap about all of them but none of them
take it like Saints fans and I'm just
saying come on what's his name
who cares there's that's just open but
what I do is I write tweeted it and then
I let the internet handle all right but
that's that's what's so interesting
about this is this is a Saints team and
a fanbase that believes it's their time
yeah and I get it I they have the team
they get to play at home they have the
second best coach in the NFL they have a
quarterback that's not going to be fazed
by anything they have a receiver that
can win a 50/50 ball against anyone they
have Alvin Kamara who can outrun anybody
when you don't like that Mark Ingram can
pound it in your face they might have
the number one offensive line in the NFL
they have three first-round picks on
their defensive line and all of them are
really really good they have a line
backing core that is solid and a corner
that can man a man on anybody and that I
mentioned their home field advantage is
crazy they can be amazing but there's
something about this Eagles team that
loves this situation yeah and I am
putting $10 on the Philadelphia Eagles
plus eight last thing I forgot to
mention to just sorry
are you picking them
in the game um what you can't give that
speech yes I I really am just
superstitious so yeah do the amount
don't worry I'm gonna have fun with left
co2 I'm gonna join the party and crap on
it so don't worry and well as long as
you're Saints fans as long as you're not
threatening to kill my co-host here okay
I will read them next week and have fun
with them
but let's not cross the line to the
Saints fans that have listened to us for
a long time
everything on this show is good fun like
I've interviewed Drew Brees numerous
times I think he's a great guy but yeah
like if I will we will that's a good
point if whatever your best insults of
me are right I will read them if you win
that's right just don't cross the line
and this the last five I like being
insulted I find it very funny I would
love to be at a roast I I hear you
the Eagles played this is the other
issue with the game in the Saints first
matchup the Eagles played man-to-man in
that game like lockdown man-to-man like
I would say 85% of the time you guys
don't really do that anymore
and that I think bodes well in your
favor just to keep the game closer and
everything I'm saying that way oh
because I would say that why you guys
might late I remember the most it was
either what made it 31 7 or 24/7 was
when Drew Brees just kind of lobbed it
down the right sideline and I was like
why are you playing this coverage
there's no safety help and I ended up
being I think the one you're talking
about an incomplete pass and there was
two receivers open down there right like
one was on the seam and was that they
were both open and Brees kind of missed
the throw I think that's the one you're
talking about but yes it was way too
much man and they were you know
outclassed that way and you guys don't
pie man like that anymore
I'm glad yeah alright so again if you're
coming to Atlanta I just had a cousin
hit me up that says he wants to go to
Super Bowl weekend how does he get
tickets I've been getting emails during
the show that I'm just answering every
email Sims and Lefko at gmail.com say
which day you want to come to Tuesday
podcast at 5:00 Wednesday podcast at
5:00 Thursday show at 6:00 Friday
podcast at 4:30 we're gonna be hanging
out beforehand probably hanging a little
bit
afterwards we're gonna have like two or
three guests every night which is gonna
be a lot of fun and we're just gonna be
shooting the [ __ ] and it's gonna be
Super Bowl week and in 1942 drink in
1945 on Bleacher Report's tab without
the three limes let me just recap these
really quick eat that we are step my
spreadsheets we are both going
Indianapolis plus five and a half we are
both taking New England minus four we
are both taking Philadelphia plus eight
we are an agreement of three of the four
Simms is putting 790 on the Eagles plus
eight which is fantastic for me as an
Eagles fan just makes me feel good but
there is a twenty three hundred dollar
difference it all comes down to Saturday
night Dallas at the Rams Shaun McVeigh
if you can do anything
destroy Dallas and if Jared Goff poops
his pants I'm gonna be at home in the
fetal position it all comes down to that
love you guys for Sims he's at homies
for fendron good evening everybody and I
am the lef koe how was my Eagles song do
you like my words it was great
any time you punch into the Eagles cheer
you're part of the tribe not as good as
my homey but it's pretty cool we will
holla holla holla at you guys later be
well I'll talk to you soon
you